so we were doing part c of the first
problem on the calculus bc exam the the
free response part
and so what i'll reread it because it
says the region r this is the region r
is the base of a solid and i redrew the
region r here but with a little
perspective so we can hopefully
visualize it in three dimensions
so it says for this solid each cross
section perpendicular to the x-axis
right there's two ways you could do a
cross-section you could do them you
could cut this way but that would be
parallel to the x-axis we wanted to cut
perpendicular to the excesses or
parallel to the y-axis right so if we
cut it
along a line like that
right so they say each cross-section
perpendicular
perpendicular to the x-axis is a square
so i drew a couple of squares here
that's one
so here
this is this would be the base and since
we know the cross section is a square
the height has to be the same length as
the base same thing here so here the
height will be really high because this
is kind of maybe our maximum point in
terms of the base width and then it's
still pretty wide there and it gets
narrow again
so how do we figure out the volume of
this solid which is kind of hard to
visualize and it's it's in some ways
easier to visualize than it is to draw
so you have to give me some credit but
anyway what we do is we take the area of
each of these squares and i drew one of
them here you take each of the area of
each of these squares
multiply them by a super small change in
x and that we know from
everything we've learned in calculus
hopefully that that super small change
in x i'm trying to draw a little
perspective is dx
so if we multiply dx times the area of
this square
that is the volume of this kind of part
of the part of the entire solid and if
we were to sum up all of these
infinitely thin
solids we would get the volume for the
whole thing so how do we do that
well let's write our integral expression
so what is
the area of each of these squares
each of these cross sections what is the
area
well the base is going to be
the difference between our two functions
right this top function right here that
was sine
of pi x
and this bottom function
right here that is y is equal to
x to the third
minus 4x so the base of the functions
the base of
this distance right here is going to be
the difference between the top
function and the bottom function so the
each base is going to be
sine
of pi x
minus this function so minus x to the
third plus 4x right switch the signs
minus x to the third plus 4x
so far this might look pretty similar to
part a but what's the twist here we want
the area the area of each of these
squares not just this distance so what's
the area it's going to be this distance
squared so we have to square
this entire thing
so that's the area of each of these
squares and then we have to multiply
them times a little bit of dx
and that gives us the volume
over for each of these i guess parts of
the entire solid and now what if our
boundaries are integration well it's the
same thing as in part a this is zero
this is two so the boundaries are pretty
straightforward
so we essentially just have to evaluate
this now
and just like in part b
i first tried to evaluate this
analytically and you end up getting a
very very very hairy integral which you
can do analytically but you have to know
some power reduction formulas in
trigonometry you have to do some
integration by parts and it would
probably use up all of the time on the
ap exam so since they said that a
graphing calculator is required for some
parts of the problem i say why not use
our graphing calculator because the
graphing calculator is very good at
evaluating numerically evaluating
definite integrals like this so let's
get out my ti-85 emulator again
here we go
and i want you to see the keystrokes so
that you okay so let me turn it on
let me
exit out of this so we're going to use
the calculus
we're going to use the calculus
function here so second
calculus
and this this function right here this
is definite integral very useful
function to use
press f5 to get our definite integral
and we just type in the expression so
the expression let me
let me move it down a little bit
so it's
open parentheses
sine
of
let me where's pi
pi is
i haven't used one of these calculators
in a long long time oh there it is
second pi
x
sine of pi x
minus
x
to the third power
plus
x
all of that
all of that squared
and then
this this definite integral function you
have to tell it which is the independent
variable or kind of you know where do we
taking this what do we what variable we
integrating across and that's the
variable x and then you just tell it the
boundaries of integration and we're done
so we're going to integrate from zero
from x equal to 0 to x is equal to 2.
and if i haven't made a mistake i can
hit enter
and let the calculator do the rest of
the work
let's see what it ends up with
notice okay 9 point and let's see so
that's the answer that is the volume of
this solid it's
9.9783 so you could write that this
is equal to
9.9783
and i think i'm pretty sure they want
you to use the calculator because
frankly computing the integral that's
kind of just you know
chug math you know very mechanical math
although it's it's pretty uh
sophisticated it would take you forever
but this is kind of i think what they
wanted you to do set up the integral
recognize that each of these squares the
area of each of these squares is just
going to be this distance the distance
between the functions squared and then
you integrate that from 0 to 2.
let's see how much time i have left
i have a couple of minutes so let's do
let's do part d
image
clear
invert colors okay part d the region r
models let me edit paste
this
actually oh i didn't want to do that
edit undo edit
repeat nope edit undo
edit paste there you go
okay so i want to make this a little bit
smaller
so what does part d say the region r
models the surface of a small pond so
that's the surface now
at all points r at a distance
x from the y axis
the depth of the water is given by h of
x is equal to three minus x so
essentially the
as well it's three minus x is the depth
right so at this point
of this pond the depth is just three
right three minus zero and at this point
the depth is three minus two which is
one so essentially the pond is going to
get shallower and shallower as we go
further to the right you could almost
imagine it let me see if i can draw it
again
so
this is the sine function with some
perspective
this is the polynomial function below it
this is
i should probably draw it
i've drawn it that's the x-axis
this is
the y-axis
that's the y-axis
and so here at the the depth of the pond
is given by the function
what did it say h of x is equal to three
minus x so over here the pond the depth
is three so if i were to draw i'll do it
in blue
so if i were to go straight down the
depth is you know maybe it's three and
then the pond essentially gets shallower
and shallower as we go to the right
right so how do we figure out how do we
figure out the volume of this so over
here what is the depth of it it's going
to be 1 right 3 minus 2 this is x is
equal to two
so here the depth is going to be one so
the if we if we take the cross section
just along the x-axis
the depth is going to look something
like this but then this is the top of it
i know that's kind of hard to visualize
but anyway how do we figure out how do
we figure out what this
what the volume of this lake is and
actually i realize i'm pushing nine
minutes so i will continue this in the
next video see you soon